I'm here with Michael ich of the Swedish
local fiber alliance Michael before we
get into the subject were going to talk
about today tell us about the Alliance
and how it came to be developed yeah the
alliances with hundra native municipal
sweden sweden and stands for more than
two third of all fiber infrastructure in
Sweden and the first municipal local
from fiber network started almost 20
years ago because they was was tired on
the monopoly for the infrastructure
actually now you guys in Swain you're
leading the world with FTTH certainly
Europe anyway and you're here tomorrow
to talk about the younger plan what do
you think of it yeah and will be a nun
panel session discussion and and I think
it it's good that we have this kind of
initiative or inform the leading people
in imbecile but we've been through this
kind of project since we need but much
smaller of course amount of money but
the lessons we learn ten years ago that
was that you have to regulate this kind
of money going out because we can see in
some municipal areas they went together
with the forum incumbent and invested at
that time 40 million euro and now it's
it's it's it's gone because they need to
start or a start again and invest them
this time hallelujah euro in a new fiber
infrastructure but most of the municipal
actually started their own local fiber
networks and and they are quite a help
today was that one of the reasons why
sweden has been so successful yes yes i
think and and it and the main thing is
that we open up their network and
therefore it's created a whole industry
of local service providers and therefore
we have one of the lowest price of a
fiber and fiber services within Europe
action
now as we said you're a flagship for
FTTH in Europe but when you at the top
there what's next what are you going to
provide next for your market yeah the
next phase about getting the society
itself into digitalization we are
talking about school education we're
talking about healthcare and nursery and
and so on and culture we need to set e
before all this world and and a desert
it is a big challenge and and that's one
of our biggest challenge for our
association to to talk about with
politicians and make them understand
what is happening well you've got the
track record I'm sure you're going to
get there thanks very much for talking
to I see thank you very much so they
heard it from Sweden already a flagship
in Europe but looking to stay there in
the future